d'après zar monsieur gérard cornu pour
le groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse arnaud
montebourg ministre du redressement
productif
monsieur le ministre chaque jour notre
pays s'enfonce un peu plus dans la crise
une crise économique d'abord mais aussi
morale
alors que la république exemplaire
promise par le président hollande a vécu
est enterré dans les conditions
calamiteuses que l'on sait alors que le
sénat débat depuis des jours sur un
sujet dit du mariage pour tout ce qui
divise les français et dont l'urgente
nécessité
continuent d'échapper au plus grand
nombre j'ai envie de vous poser la
question essentielle où va l'économie
française
pendant ce temps en effet les dernières
prévisions passées inaperçues traduit
une réalité économique alarmante
croissance zéro en 2014 déficit
budgétaire de quatre et demi pourcent
endettement proche de 100% du pib'
déficit extérieur et chômage accru et
cela sans aucune garantie de reprise en
2015 que fait le gouvernement
après arcelormittal et l'arrêt des hauts
fourneaux de florange décidé en ce
moment
lundi c'est l'équipementier automobile
heuliez qui annonçait son dépôt de bilan
280 emplois sont menacés on apprend ce
matin que le lien est placée en
redressement judiciaire
un sursis cette affaire en tout cas dans
un secteur très durement touché par la
crise est exemplaire hélas pour ne pas
dire symbolique de l'incapacité de ce
gouvernement à apporter des réponses
efficaces à des réalités que le mit
qu'il ne connaît pas et auquel il tente
d'appliquer des solutions idéologique
monsieur le ministre on ne peut vouloir
tout et son contraire
d'accès et décourager les automobilistes
et en même temps se plaindre que la
filière automobile va mal il faut être
cohérent
au-delà du cas heuliez ce sont de
nombreuses petites entreprises sous
traitantes qu'on appelle les
équipementiers de deuxième rang qui
irrigue l'ensemble de notre territoire
et qui souffre par manque de commandes
et donc de travail ces petits patrons
n'en peuvent plus et toute la filière
est en danger la précédente majorité
avaient mis en place des mécanismes de
soutien avec raison et lucidité la
question s'il vous plaît
pouvez vous nous préciser les actions
que vous entendez mener pour préserver
non seulement oliech mais aussi toute la
filière automobile
très bien merci la parole à monsieur
montebourg ministre du redressement
productif
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs reçu le sénateur
cornu vous évoquez la filière automobile
et vous évoquez à juste titre sur un
point le cas de ces entreprises
invisible celle dont on ne parle pas qui
ne sont pas les constructeurs donneurs
d'ordre qui sont dans nos territoires et
qui subissent par contre coup les
affaiblissements de marché ce n'est pas
seulement la france c'est toute l'europe
c'est une question européenne
- 16 en espagne - 20 en france - 22 en
italie même en allemagne nous sommes à
moins 5 le seul endroit où cela
progresse et au royaume uni mais partout
ailleurs et particulièrement dans les
pays de la zone euro les affaissements
de commandes la diminution de la
consommation y est générale et
structurelles et les questions de
taxation que vous évoquez n'y sont
d'ailleurs pas corrélés qu'est ce que le
gouvernement fait d'abord des mesures
d'urgence je voudrais vous donner
quelques exemples de la façon dont nous
organisons le sauvetage non pas pour le
sauvetage mais parce que nous voulons
préserver nos outils industriels nos
savoir-faire nos technologies nos
ingénieurs autant que nous le pouvons et
tout le monde accepte autour de la table
le ciri les commissaires redressement
productif dans les préfectures des
sacrifices bien sûr les salariés les
premiers qui perdent leur emploi pas
tous nous essayons donc conserver le
plus possible les actionnaires l'état
qui abandonnent une partie des créances
les créanciers qui en abandonne aussi et
nous faisons finalement face pour
maintenir notre tissu industriel c'est
notre stratégie à l'allemande je prends
quelques exemples de succès si lynx à
charleval dans l'eure nous avons sauvé
avec les constructeurs mbf technologies
dans le haut jura nous avons sauvé la
fonderie d'aluminium qui était menacée
de disparition c'est un succès avec les
constructeurs je veux parler de sora
dans le loir-et-cher l'ille-et-vilaine
la mayenne 500 emplois préservés racheté
par faurecia avec des équipementiers de
rang 1 c'est un travail au cas par cas
nous connaissons des succès parfois des
échecs parfois des demi succès ou des
deux mis ses échecs alors monsieur le
sénateur maintenant vous évoquer les
questions macroéconomiques
d'ordre général bien sûr nous nous
battons pour la réorientation de l'union
européenne ce qu'a dit le président de
la république pour la croissance nous
avons été élus pour cela parce que
précisément nous avons connu la
récession pendant cinq ans et vous qui
ne semblait pas vouloir louer les
efforts du gouvernement je voudrais vous
dire monsieur le sénateur que les 600
milliards de dettes que nous avons à
rembourser elles ne sont pas tombés par
l'opération de la sainte vierge elles
sont tombés parce qu'il ya des gens qui
ont vécu au-dessus de leurs moyens et je
crains que vous ayez soutenu certains
gouvernements qu'ils aient commis
quelques abus en la matière un million
de chômeurs de plus en cinq ans 600
milliards de dettes de plus en cinq ans
70 milliards de déficit du commerce a
cédé en cinq ans monsieur le sénateur la
modestie pourrait être la manière
d'aborder les sujets qui nous sont comme
merci